yeah welcome to another video this is
some chess cube tournament coming up
here the King fresh a tournament it's a
ten thousand cubits first prize no this
total price front right yeah but it's a
rather highly prized tournament so let's
see what happens not too many m
competitors at the moment at 30 minutes
so not so long the Dutch defense try for
something quickly here get some active
play going on leave on the ldh file and
now open up the position quickly Lex got
a somewhat we at night on a jade ok you
need to move as king now otherwise e5 is
lost so let's hope i can i can get
something going with the better
development ok we can give a check first
and maybe 95 if it takes me for i can
like in grab c7 so how would I improve
now you should see for me looks like an
active move yeah should be somewhat
better okay I don't mind that I want to
get a not only for anyway yeah this is
some the materialistic way to to go
about this okay let's take the edge far
the four point I will get them back
anyway I guess now I get a four or even
need to take yeah and I've got also this
be four threat catching the night so 96
now threatened and before so this should
win some material don't you don't know
how we would prevent both don't solve
this is some quite awkward for black
yeah it tries everything there is but I
think at the end I'll get this night it
still doesn't have any square so a 96
hours also possible maybe naughty for ya
it winds up is anyway okay so wind first
start let's play abalone okay just
ignored it yeah this is a weird kind of
know nomura type of plane so I'm
basically just a pawn up he's got good
development though yeah I want to show
up the King side here with g6 Bishop g7
so that's no no no no no you won't
second g6 right before is also possible
now if for and g5 should win the night
doesn't have any square yeah so I got
this piece nice okay let's win at
empower first then player 5 securing all
this and now Bishop have six and route
d8 ok first crap then look the aid next
move getting rid of at least one pair of
rooks oh now resigned all right I was
just a piece up okay but some guy
already won three games so you to speed
up yeah always like that always feels
like good position to me with some space
advantage and possible attacking chances
right i want to prepare c3 slow
shouldn't blunder the Queen alright so
maybe he wants to get long castles in so
I tried to play with c4 even dance been
not terribly good but her but very quick
not quite sure what's happening here
why AC so quick the idea is not to play
d5 this is roxy one it tends to cd5 ya
want to play this anyway now this Bishop
is attacking the rook so I should lose
some material now ok first grab this was
check and still the rookies hanging yeah
don't want him to make me on the long
diagonal so try to Queen to h6 would be
really really nice so maybe first this
threatening rook takes and rub the eight
made also Queen h6 yeah once made next
move rupee ages the only move yep but
some guy still has got four out of four
yeah the Trump I know this check was
right here ok yes'm
typically we add chopped off ski
position you don't really know what's
going on want to get rid of the dark
squared Bishop because of the dark
squares are wats problem in this
position okay maybe this one right I
want to be able to a yeah do this
recapture and this is nice now c3f for
all this week okay i want to make sure
that this Bishop is a good piece get it
here and now maybe Bishop g4 this is
nice light c5e for the next idea I've
got very nice sum squares for my pieces
try to double on the e-file okay i think
i need to play this get some inroads
here this night is still controlling e2
can i need to need to get rid of this
now weighing the way to make any
progress without that Queen f5 to h3
would be really cute okay prevented this
but I can take care right 22 it's also
quite dangerous Queen d2 in the rook h2
stuff like this okay what is it doing
now brooke edge to seems tough to meet
exactly yeah what is this guy doing with
1,900 rating 5 out of 5 so quickly okay
yeah play some solid opening maybe
getting some pressure here on d 695 can
I take on whom take on e5 takes e4 text
e6 okay some may be interesting I should
get c4 also hopefully i can pick up a
six yeah so I've got three plans for
this side for this piece and the d6 pawn
he wants to exchange not sure not sure I
want to do that rather try to win more
time on the queen with rocky one
hmm yeah let's show this is also great
94 some idea okay it didn't do again
anything again this and I need to to
cover this the sea 61 and 95 194 looks
tricky maybe I can can color this oops i
can just retake yeah now he's giving
everything away in just a couple of
moves yeah I know but this is made even
push up fa to h6 only play rook c8 or
just 98 or nothing at all yeah I guess
nothing at all
I come on yeah one of those non movers
at the end facing a mate they just let
the clock run down don't really get it
cling yeah this guy here so has got
relatively weaker position six out of
six is still strong come on give me a
new game I need to catch up here right
yeah my special line against the Kings
gambit has won lots of games f take c5f
take C 4 wins and 95 95 every five Queen
edge fold so and so why just got to move
that loose instantly and lots of people
actually play it yeah okay the rook is
the look of the rook so okay let's let's
drop back here exchange Queens with the
piece up should be a bad policy maybe
it's got Bishop g2 now okay let's try
this want to get rid of the Queen oil or
get it back into my own camp okay can
just stop Queen g6 next move
hmm it's got a bit bit of compensation
for further rook that's a look so okay
let's keep it closed only problem he has
some bit down on time or not really I
was just thinking that because it felt
very slow to me my plane okay still look
up not much happening we need to be
cautious about bishop h5 or some stupid
move then I don't overlook this yes so I
can cancel long now threatening night
excel form you can let's get rid of all
the material here it's still on extra
work 27 d 4 or something yeah this is an
awfully long game for winning a rook so
early not quite sure it may play the
some to passively okay some tight now
with the other guy six out of six
yeah so we transpose into an oxy bind
with a quick we need a 595 or so what
yeah you cannot really take this but 95
coming so now I need to take and the
shirt should be quite nice got the look
on the C file already don't leave me
here Queen B form okay let me enter I
like the square yeah should I take with
Rocco with a pawn both good okay have to
see file now cannot really move much yes
just playing quickly kale I'll win some
space IAM take a little bit on age 6 all
right let's grab this and just drop back
um I could also take with the Queen
right should be a nice post for the
Queen no take b5 yeah why not
maybe ruka a six roocase six exchanging
rook now hanging queen hanging so I
think he needs to exchange now okay this
was also hanging now f7 right so wow
it's gone half point don't see that
often yeah still on on 100% run here
let's hope it continues this way yeah
the Scotch gambit one of those moves
mostly am incorrect openings but I still
need to be cautious g5 is the key move
to get the the get pressure on this f
three Pawn likes goal is to to play
against the week porn CM when you have
695 stuff like this okay not sure what
is doing with this Queen just some
reroute Aang basically okay don't mind
95 will come up anyway the problem is he
has got nothing developed here on the
queenside not really what you want with
the gambit 95 looks
looks rather strong rope age six is
solar Scott Queen 2 g-3 night d3 in my
play any night move all right maybe just
putting more pressure on the pawn rook
f8 want to play with all my pieces and I
definitely don't want to exchange Queens
okay fate is coming okay first retreat
this and then rook evade yeah very nice
position on rook evade instantly I could
have taking on deform group so okay is
trying to sack the Queen already but I
want the Queen anyway look at 3am now f3
is stung yep okay so 20 points ahead
here with eight out of eight let's just
keep winning and I think I should have
it yeah this needs low trick Colette's
transpose into a more are always some
good fun
really hmm looks weird to put the bishop
out and then yeah the shortly deter
should lead to some trouble takes on
before it's not too bad mighty form okay
let's let's grab those come on to create
a play quick am should be a nice for me
anyway the d6 porn is just um close to
getting lost ok but just rip d5 the
queen is on YouTube ok ok let's keep it
simple alright so it tries to pin the
bishop quite annoying yeah whoops e8
mm-hmm rook c8 maybe I maybe I must just
take it I didn't really kept it simple
as I intended to do completely
unnecessary
I need to get out of this dreadful pin
on the back rank at least now I can move
this Bishop 9054 would cover the porn
yeah now I'm coordinated again before b5
yeah this wasn't the greatest player
them yeah but these pawns really should
win now b7 to come
yeah really made it much more difficult
than necessary so nine out of nine can I
make it ten out of ten hmm go on yeah
it's not our forty four players now not
too many players in this tournament yeah
it's really a slow on those chat service
at the moment I guess people watching
the Olympics a lot hmm i don't get a
game this way i might even not win this
thing if i don't get games would be bit
bit awful not to win with i have died
okay so yeah okay guess the Stonewall
reversed it is it's always so nice to
play and to play Bishop t6 and possibly
h h 6 and g5 maybe yeah g5 now just
trying to rip up the structure
immediately can even take d for now
let's try this Bishop c5 once the Queen
if it takes it and otherwise is Sam at
central porn queen a4 may be okay
but here maybe he's got something with
what is Queen Queen B 5 or something I
tried try to record on the G file there
should be four maybe I can play Knight
c3 and then this isn't so totally clear
9527 queen bee [ __ ] will be 500 what am
I doing here it just takes me seven next
move and then the rook is saying and
it's it's made on on f7 yeah not much
that I can do queen bee sadness just
winning now it's not not a mate at least
I hope or winning the Queen very stupid
very stupid play oh this is strong ah
double double check mate yeah amazing
I don't see move on the tournament is
over just before I got I got made it
here wow I really sport this completely
winning position quickly yeah this is
just over Queen g6 check man and a g6
made did nothing I can do yeah now I'm
not Rick Roderick even ruku g2 is not
working yeah right so that made it nine
out of nine but was lucky in the end the
the bell saved me so to say yes thanks
for watching